now turning to the first television
interview with huma abedin hillary
clinton's longtime aide abedin spoke
with cbs evening news anchor and
managing editor nora o'donnell to
discuss her new book both and a life in
many worlds it's published by scribner
an imprint of simon schuster a division
of viacom cbs and on cbs sunday morning
aberdeen discussed her marriage to
disgrace former new york congressman
anthony weiner and how that scandal
affected her job
by 2016 anthony weiner and huma abedin
were officially separated a month after
hillary clinton became the democratic
nominee for president yet another
bombshell
this picture of weiner in bed with their
young son was leaked that triggered an
investigation by child protective
services they're showing up at your
apartment all the time checking on the
well-being of your son were you worried
you would lose your son yes ask any
parent what it feels like
that somebody is judging whether you're
a fit parent and whether you can keep
your child it's hard to put in words a
few weeks later abedine's two lives
truly came crashing together
weiner was caught sexting with an
underage girl and fbi agents found
emails involving hillary clinton on his
laptop
just 11 days before the election fbi
director james comey announced he was
reopening an investigation into
clinton's emails he would finally close
the probe two days before election day
but many considered the damage had been
done
you're right this man weiner was going
to ruin me and now he was going to
jeopardize hillary clinton's chances of
winning the presidency and then you
write you called anthony weiner and you
said what anthony i said wanting to
shake him through the phone
if she loses this election it will be
because of you and me
that night i wrote one line in my
notebook i do not know how i am going to
survive this help me god
yeah
i've just received a call
from secretary clinton it all ended of
course with hillary clinton losing to
donald trump
the debate over what caused her defeat
however has never ended hillary clinton
could be in her second term as president
right now
that is a thought that crosses my mind
probably more than it crosses hers that
is something that lives here
that
i think i'm going to take to my grave
when you say take it to your grave do
you mean because you think about
something you could have done to help
fix the situation make it better because
you're kind of in that fix-it role i
have reconciled and it took me a while
to reconcile that it was not all my
fault i lived with that i did i don't
believe that anymore it's more a sense
of
an ache in the heart
nora o'donnell is joining us right now
good morning so norah this is a very
honest and revealing interview is this
just about her promoting the book or is
it deeper than that
i do think it's deeper than that i think
huma abedin is someone who has been a
private person
largely for the past 25 years as a
hillary clinton aide more public of
course when her husband ran
for mayor of new york but i told i asked
her i said this is your first television
interview this woman has never done a
television interview until our piece on
sunday morning and she said she did it
because she said she realized that if
you don't tell your story someone else
is writing your history it is one of the
most powerful interviews i have ever
done the book is actually one of the
best books i've ever read i'm not in the
business of of
pushing someone's book but she is a
fascinating person that i've known you
know someone who was with hillary
clinton i'm a reporter but i didn't know
her personally she starts off the book
talking about her parents her mother
from pakistan her father from india both
fulbright scholars growing up in saudi
arabia really never ever having a
boyfriend until anthony weiner is really
the only man she's been with and then of
course living her life in this very
public scandal and that giant question
mark which we talk about in this
interview did her relationship with
anthony weiner and those discovered
emails on his laptop somehow lead to
hillary clinton's defeat it's utterly
fascinating it is still an ongoing
question that many people still debate
to this day but norah listen i thought
it was extremely powerful but i thought
she was good but i thought you were
stellar i think it's very difficult to
talk to someone about something that's
so painful so public and so personal and
she did that you both really went all
the way there i think many people
thought that hillary clinton would act
over here patty okay patty's arm's about
to come off
i'll look like daddy too
yeah
many people thought that hillary clinton
and puma that their their relationship
would be fractured after that
um and i think people still are
surprised that it wasn't why do you
think that the two of them are still
extremely close even today
you know it's so interesting uh hillary
clinton has described huma abedine as
her second daughter
and
and huma said to me that everything in
their relationship has been about whom
is well-being first and then their
professional relationship they're
extremely close
and to this day huma abedin is her chief
of staff so she's been working for her
for 25 years however i did ask her
what's next and she kept talking about a
reawakening a rebirth i wonder whether
there is something different in the
future for huma abedin whether it's a
different role or a job where it's a
life in public service as a political
candidate herself i think those are all
potential options in the future uh for
huma abedin
laura we have to go so please answer
this very quickly sure women everywhere
want to know and by women i mean me how
she continued to stay with him time
after time especially when you revealed
yesterday that he was also having sex
with women in their home yes
i think right after this big cycle cycle
of betrayal over and over again i think
yeah it has to do with her son you have
to remember that she was 12 weeks
pregnant when the first public betrayal
happened with the pictures she talks
about a financial decision between the
two of them caring for their son and
then there's more on that but um they
are currently separated and finalizing
their divorce
all right cheering for huma thank you no
doubt and great stuff as usual norah
yeah thank you so much